[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct sur avis de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir prudence sur les
retraites le gouvernement remet à
septembre la réforme qui fâche les
français beaucoup plus prudent sur le
recul de l'âge de départ il semble déjà
esquissé des issues de secours alors
pretty l'emprunt de calais ou simplement
de reculer pour mieux sauter c'est l'une
des questions de notre bon débat ce soir
avec nos invités notre grand témoin et
membre du giec le times l'a classé parmi
les 100 personnalités les plus
influentes dans le monde a fait partie
de ceux qui pensent qu'il n'est pas trop
tard pour agir malgré les nombreux
signaux d'alarmé à du réchauffement
climatique valérie masson delmotte est
avec nous se soit enfin d'autres ont
déjà franchi pour leur parti pris aucun
autre campagne zelda mondain gabart
comme chaque soir sur les législatives
-les regard de richard wehrli sur les
nouvelles sanctions européennes sur la
table contre les oligarques russes et
puis l'analyse d'isabelle la faire sur
le marchandage politique d'erdogan passe
à l'otan voilà pour le menu ce soir
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs c'est le chiffon rouge
dans cette campagne des législatives le
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite
alors le nouveau ministre du travail
olivier dussopt pts a commencé à tâter
le terrain avec les syndicats et le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il sait
arrondir les angles à quoi peut-on
s'attendre et que faut-il comprendre
bonsoir astrid panossian et merci d'être
avec nous ce soir vous êtes candidate
aux législatives dans la 4e
circonscription de paris candidate
ensemble c'est la bannière qui rassemble
la majorité présidentielle peut-être
parmi donc les futurs visage ici même à
l'assemblée nationale vous êtes aussi la
cofondatrice du mouvement en marche à sa
naissance donc en 2010 est autant dire
que vous étiez là au tout début de
l'aventuré macro nien bonsoir corinne
lhaïk histoire et merci d'être à nouveau
sur ce plateau radio vous retrouvez
journalistes à l'opinion vous signez un
grand papier en une retraite déjà des
doutes sur la réforme on en parlera
olivier dussopt pts que vous comparez un
dentiste qui saurait s'y prendre bonsoir
philippe aghion soit ravi également de
vous compter parmi nous vous êtes
évidemment économiste professeur au
collège de france à la london school of
economics également lycéens de et aline
ca d'affronter jo merci de me le
rappeler vous militez pour l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation plutôt que
pour le report de l'âge légal de départ
vous nous direz pourquoi pascale coton
vice-présidente de la cftc la
confédération française des travailleurs
chrétiens va nous rejoindre dans un tout
petit instant elle est la négociatrice
sur les retraites mais d'abord le billet
de stéphane blakowski pour nous planter
le décor comme chaque soir si j'ai bien
compris ce projet sur les retraites à
quelques épines en moins c'est à vous
tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous si j'ai bien
compris ce soir alors si j'ai bien
compris myriam le candidat mâcon a fait
une campagne de droite puisque sa mesure
phare c'était la retraite à 65 ans donc
non il a été réélu et surtout maintenant
que mélenchon et son principal opposant
ces mesures de droite eh bien il a l'air
d'être moins pressé la mettre en
application dans l'immédiat sa priorité
c'est la même que pour tout le monde le
pouvoir d'achat donc avant de reculer
l'âge légal du départ à la retraite le
gouvernement va commencer par indexées
les pensions sur l'inflation qu'est ce
que c'était que l'indexation nos
téléspectateurs de savenay est-ce que
les écouteurs d'air des auditeurs d'rtl
le savent un peu de démagogie à
l'écologie et du soft
quand je parle d'addiction si on tient
compte d'une inflation à 4 % ça signifie
que pour une pension à 1200 euros c'est
un gain d'environ 45 euros par mois ça
n'est pas négligeable
45 euros par mois donc on peut se faire
une soirée à la pizzeria en plein
jeu couvrir sur le report de l'âge légal
sujets qui fâchent alors c'est pour
quand bah ça devrait commencer à la
rentrée mais la vraie question c'est pas
quand ça commence et quand sa fille il
sort les négociations officielles alors
oui on se parlait avant mais là le vrai
début des négociations à la rentrée la
preuve lui prononcé quand est ce que
vous avez fini d'autant que on se
souvient que lors de premier quinquennat
la grande promesse du maquereau c'était
la réforme des retraites et il a échoué
je sais mais il a échoué la crise
sanitaire
la crise a dit et peut-être aussi un peu
de manque de concertation je ne crois
pas mais je vous rappelle quand même
qu'au départ la cfdt est favorable à la
retraite que proposait macron par
répartition et puis président mâcon a
réussi à se fâcher avec laurent berger
ce qui n'est pas facile mais c'est ce
que fait un maquereau rien d'impossible
pour lui donc est ce que il ya un
nouveau macron qui va permettre
d'entamer une nouvelle forme
négociations il y avait de bonnes à 10
65 ans n'est pas un totem et puis
olivier dussopt pts encore le dentiste
qui ne fait pas mal et c'est vrai qu
elle a pas l'air si terrible cette
réforme des retraites quand il en parle
ce que nous cherchons à construire et
c'est l'objet des discussions c'est
l'objet de la recherche d'un consensus
je ne dis pas qu'ils sont faciles je dis
qu'il faut chercher des consensus
c'est construire une réforme qui soit à
la fois juste et responsable juste c'est
améliorer le système de retraite que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui la précarité
n'est pas assez prise en compte la
pénibilité n'est pas assez irresponsable
parce qu'il faut que ça tienne
financièrement dans le dos nous
connaissions iv du soft oui moi je le
connaissais mes sermons travaillant même
tout ça en 20 secondes on y réfléchit
très vite ne se fasse jamais mais c'est
super profits de négociateurs surtout
s'il tombe sur les forces au négoce a
cessé alors justement et c'est pas si
c'est un forcené en tout cas ils avaient
rendez-vous il recevait même dans son
ministère philippe martinez delà de la
cgt aujourd'hui alors bien sûr que
philippe hargneuse n'est pas un forcené
d'aller y aurait un sort de malentendus
dans notre enchaînements en plus je le
connais bien et fils est parti neige
puisque il l a vu d'abord du soap
ensuite elisabeth bornes qui était muni
du travail donc ils se connaissent on
peut imaginer que leurs conversations
sont assez franches on imagine que jls
et burn a dû lui dire enfin philippe
soyez raisonnable ou et bien que tous
les pays d'europe ont augmenté l'âge de
la retraite vous pouvez quand même pas
avoir raison contre tout le monde
philippe réponse de martinez quand on
regarde autour de nous en europe
quasiment tous les pays un travail plus
tard que nous plus certains sont passés
à 65 ans et même d'autres au-delà c'est
à dire qu'ils se trompent tous en tout
cas les gouvernements de ces pays là oui
et oui c'est pas facile de négocier avec
la cgt donc elle peut peut-être jouer
sur la corde sensible sur le thème
philippe je suis de gauche comme vous
moi aussi je me soucie du sort des
pauvres gens et donc insister sur la
pénibilité le fait que le gouvernement
veut vraiment faire des réformes là
dessus réponse de martinez
c'est ce même gouvernement qui en
arrivant à supprimer trois critères de
pénibilité alors vous me dites est ce
qu'on peut les croire moi je regarde les
faits et il nous parle de pénibilité
aujourd'hui et quand ils sont arrivés
dans le précédent quinquennat ils ont
supprimé trois critères voilà trois
critères mais ils reviendront ces
critères macro on attend de le voir hier
face et pour les syndicats dans
l'opposition comme on réagit aux arènes
on reste de très très basique sébastien
chenu sur sud radio ce matin croyez pas
qu'ils se soient embêtés à parler du
nombre d'annuités du système de décote
des régimes complémentaires non simple
basique ça m'inquiète parce que quand
c'est flou et un loup quand vous pensez
que ça n'a même pas été évoquée au
premier conseil des ministres on va bien
qu'une aile vaincre on attend que
législatives soient passées pour
dégainer et pour installer une réforme
des retraites particulièrement dure
vis-à-vis des français c'est un peu
sommaire mais vu que les électeurs du
rnd tess macron il suffit de dire du mal
de macron pour leur fera plaisir voilà
c'est pour terminer chez mélenchon
parce qu'ils connaissent leur dossier
chez mélenchon mais ça peut poser aussi
des problèmes ce matin alexis corbière
et donc sur bfm et on lui fait remarquer
qu'avec les 40 annuités qui propose un
jeune qui commence à travailler à 25 ans
il se retrouve à la retraite à 65 ans ok
dit corps bien je vous expliquais dont
on supprime le système de décote cette
système de pénalités qui fait que la
parade - si on part plus tôt c'est pas
facile expliqué vous allez voir vous
comprenez ce que je en train de vous
dire qu'à repartir on vous supprimez la
décôte si quelqu'un n'a pas la totalité
de ses 40 trimestre certes il aura un
peu moins mais il aura pas la double
peine à vif est décoté l'existant mais
sera moins importante pardon je vous ai
dit qu'elle était supprimé et je vous ai
dit qu'elle est
ne veut pas se fâcher alexis corbière et
voilà qui paraît hyper méprisant un
petit peu comme macron quand il parlait
à le pen voyez comme quoi ça peut
arriver ce genre de show débat d'entre
deux tours sauf qu'il faudrait quand
même faire un référendum sur les
retraites que ça obligera les français à
s'y intéresser manifestement tout le
monde n'a pas suivi le dossier est à
écouter c'est une proposition pas sûr
qu'elle soit suivie merci que françois
bayrou que du saut c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais pas toujours suivies france au
maire merci beaucoup stéphane je me
tourne vers vous corinne d'abord parce
que il ya les mots qui sont prononcés et
puis il ya aussi la coulisse qu'est ce
qui se passe au sommet de l'état sur les
retraites en ce moment on a l'impression
qu'on change complètement de stratégie
il faut bien voir qu'on est dans une
période de campagne pour les
législatives qu'emmanuel macron veut
gagner cette élection et qu'il sait bien
qu'il n'a pas trop parce intérêts a
insisté lourdement sur le dossier
retraites surtout quand il s'agit de
monter l'âge légal de départ donc il ya
un peu des considérations tactiques ce
qui fait qu'il n'est pas très pressé
d'en parler cela dit même après les
élections législatives c'est un dossier
à haut risque donc il est en train
d'opérer une opération de déminage avec
olivier du soft comme vous l'avez
souligné
en dentiste qui sait manier la roulette
sans faire mal à personne c'est un peu
ce qu'il a dit hier il intervenu sur la
cas elle est il a esquissé jeudi bien
esquissé parce que formellement il n'a
pas dit des choses que je vais dire mais
ça se déduisait de skill de son
raisonnement qui était de dire qu' il
avait peut-être un autre moyen pour que
les français travaillent davantage
qu'ils n'étaient pas de jouer sur l'âge
légal de départ mais d'augmenter la
durée de cotisation cette durée de
cotisation est en train d'augmenter du
fait d'une réforme faite par marisol
touraine en 2014 elle est actuellement
autour de quarante deux années elle
arrivera à quarante trois années en 2035
pour la génération des gens né en 1973
devront alors 62 ans et il est question
il pourrait être question d'accélérer
cette montée vers les quarante trois ans
alors ça c'est quand même un gros singe
troyon soit ici si ça arrive oui oui
j'insiste sur le fait que c'est pas
quelque chose que olivier dussopt pts a
dit explicitement cela se déduit de ses
propos mais c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui sonne agréablement aux
oreilles des syndicats qui tant qu'à
faire des sacrifices pour la retraite
préfère le faire sous la forme d'une
hausse de la durée de cotisation que le
carnage légal d'accueil de l'âge légal
plus lointain c'est très clair en tout
cas ce qu'on comprend et ça c'est une
certitude c'est que tout est ouvert le
ministre lui même l'a dit astrid
panossian vous n'aviez pas compris comme
moi qu'emmanuel macron promettait
pendant la campagne présidentielle de
reculer l'âge légal de départ moi ce que
j'avais compris au delà du 65 ans qui
est le comment c'est le pourquoi et le
pourquoi c'est d'abord de défendre la
décence des pensions et c'est le sujet
de l'indexation c'est aussi le sujet
d'augmenter le minimum retraite à 1100
euros à partir de 2023 et c'est
également de pérenniser la soutenabilité
financière
de 60 c'est également je me sens inverse
vers la représentant de la cftc
reprendre aussi les réalités du marché
du travail qui sont les carrières
hachées avec beaucoup de femmes la
pénibilité et ça a été discuté sur les
critères et je pense qu'il ya peut-être
une vocation discuter sur les critères
aujourd'hui et puis les carrières
longues alors ça ça s'appelle pas
répondre à une question non mais
média en campagne les 65 en l'espace de
cinq ans sont une modalité il ya aussi
arrêter l'allongement c'était un choix
politique aussi dans par les critiques
il avait déjà reculé sur ses 65 ans
puisque dès le 11 avril lendemain du
premier tour il dit à bor 64 et plus
peut-être un peu ce sens sur sûr étalée
dans le temps parce qu'il faut aussi
agir en responsabilité je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait un diagnostic partagé
aujourd'hui hélas le corps le dit sur le
court terme il ya 10 milliards d'euros
de déficit chaque année si on fait un
cumul s'affaissa sur le 50 cana ça fait
50 milliards ça fait presque le budget
de l'éducation nationale ces deux couacs
des unités intérieures agir
l'instabilité financière leurs efforts
d'investissement dans l'avenir la
transition énergétique la
réindustrialisation les 65 ans ne sont
pas un totem mêmes jeux reculer l'âge
légal n'est plus un impératif on peut le
dire ce soir je pense que tout est mis
sur la table il ya une chose pour agir
sur un régime par répartition il ya le
niveau des pensions ça effectivement on
va pas agir sur niveau des pensions va
plutôt à l'améliorer eu égard au
contexte inflationniste
il ya la durée des annuités c'est ce qui
a pu être évoqué par le ministre du
travail et il ya l'âge de départ légal
de la retraite en je pense que il faut
mettre tous les sujets sur la table
parce que agir en responsabilité c'est
aussi prendre en compte l'état de la
société qui deux ans après le coc vide
est une société fatiguée et on a besoin
de continuer cette transformation dans
une société pas l'avoir dit pendant la
campagne simplement je pense qu'il y
avait besoin d'avoir un discours de
réalité sur l'urgence à avancer sur le
dossier des retraites et c'est ce qui a
été fait et c'est ce qui a été mis sur
la table en disant qu'on n'a pas peur de
dire les choses et qu'il va falloir
l'échangé aussi m'ont un peu de tact
écossais peut-être nom et pas du tout
possible de rétablir de la tactique mais
en tout cas le fait est qu'on doit
pouvoir en discuter et de discuter dans
la concertation c'est pourquoi je suis
très heureuse que ces discussions
commencent en septembre pour se donner
le temps et pas en juillet valls avait
initialement pensé voilà le calendrier
il évolue aussi les très bonnes choses
au cou et assez vite philippe aghion on
entend très clairement cette nouvelle
petite musique plus personne insiste ce
que j'ai sur la réforme avions voulu
expliquer le pourquoi l'allongement de
la durée de cotisation est la meilleure
option pour vous et la plus juste déjà
d'abord les la plus juste parce que vous
voulez pas pénaliser des gens qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt et en
général c'est des gens à plus faible
espérance de vie et donc les moins
qualifiés et en fait si vous mettez un
âge minimum et bien le risque c'est que
vous faites ça oblige il en fait un
transfert de ces gens peut qualifier
avec est faible espérance de vie vers
des gens plus qualifiés avec grandes
espérances donc si vous voulez je donc
c'est toujours assez injuste de faire
une mesure d'âge en tant que tel je
trouve que c'est beaucoup plus juste de
faire durée de cotisation en tenant
compte de la pénibilité du travail donc
je sens qu'on va s'orienter vers ces
banques là bas on voit bien consciente
et ça je pense que c'est le plus et le
plus juste et je veux revenir sous peu
donc la durée de cotisation quoi
augmenter la durée de cotisation
parce que en fait c'est d'abord ça
permet de pérenniser le système des
retraites de l'équilibré à long terme et
surtout c'est un effet macroéconomiques
parce qu'en faisant ça vous augmenter le
taux d'emploi et le taux d'activité et
donc vous fait augmenter le pipe de un
an et demi pour cent très vite et c'est
ça vous comprenez tout la stratégie
économique c'est de dire on va devoir
investir dans l'éducation dans la
transition énergétique dans la
réindustrialisation par l'innovation à
l'un des grands obstacles à 122 défend
le pouvoir d'achat il faut soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat et éviter la spirale
prix salaires ça ça dépend eh bien il
faut être crédible vis-à-vis des des
investisseurs internet fai et de nous et
de nos partenaires européens et il faut
augmenter le taux d'activité donc donc
il a seul moyen c'est d'augmenter le
taux d'activité est la manière juste de
le faire c'est la durée de cotisation
est là on va revenir dans le deuil a
beaucoup de physique en moyens etc dont
tu parlais tout à l'heure qui était la
baisse des prestations l'augmentation
des cotisations ça ça réduit le taux
d'activité et ça ça coûte et cette
baisse le pouvoir d'achat tandis que là
avec l'augmentation de la durée de
cotisation vous augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat vous augmentez taux d'activité
d'un contrat et vous rendez vous donner
une cohérence à jour et aucun besoin
d'un minimum j'ai toujours dit depuis le
début alors l'instant on n'est pas on a
fêté à m'arrêter était purement un
marqueur bonsoir pascale coton et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes la
vice-présidente de la cftc vous entendez
ce débat se dérouler on sait que c'est
un chiffon rouge pour vous les l'âge
légal le recul de l'âge légal que ce
soit 64 65 si j'ai bien compris ça ça
vous ferait descendre dans la réforme la
réforme touraine qui commence seulement
en 2020 nous sommes en 2022 on va
augmenter tous d'un trimestre où les
trois ans jusqu'en 2035 on est déjà en
train de nous dire vous avez à peine
commencée on va vous demander de
travailler encore plus longtemps sans
travailler sur la pénibilité y a plus
que trois critères sans répondre à ceux
qui sont sur des carrières longues va
bien falloir le répondent sans répondre
sur les petites pensions je demande si
tony sur la pénibilité sur les femmes on
sait tout qu'une femme sur dix les
assauts du seuil de pauvreté ce qu'on
appelle aux faces que je dis souvent les
trous dans la raquette la retraite c'est
le miroir de votre vie professionnelle
il ya tous ces trous dans la raquette
que subissent les femmes pour élever un
enfant pour s'occuper d'une personne
dépendante pour le chômage etc et puis
le fait que 85 % des gens qui sont au
smic ce sont des femmes donc
automatiquement au bout du bout ça se
retrouve pour nous c'est fait et c'est
ce que l'on dise et arrêtons de parler
de l'âge 64 65 et pourquoi pas 66 67 on
a déterminé un moment donné dans une loi
qu'il fallait tout ce que l'on aille
travailler tant de trimestre eh bien on
a un contrat moral avec l'état tout le
monde va travailler le nombre de
trimestre en enlevant pénibilité en
enlevant les carrières longues et c'est
ce qui est en train de se passer c'est
que ça fait peur aux salariés en se
disant oui effectivement on sera
peut-être encore obligés de redescendre
mais là on décide à une réforme qui n'a
rien à voir avec celle qu'a fait élire
pardonnez moi et là elle m'a bien
évidemment en 2000 ce qui est dommage
excusez moi mais ce qui est dommage
c'est que les organisations syndicales
nous avons tous travaillé pendant 18
mois sous la responsabilité de monsieur
delevoye on avait mis en avant tout ce
qui a fait renaître cette finale hier à
l'ancien monsieur retraites on avait
vraiment bien travaillé sur le sujet
tout à coup le qu'ovide arrive
malheureusement il a fallu arrêter les
débats on se disait mais toute cette
richesse que nous avons tous les débats
que nous avons eus où on était d'accord
ou pas d'accord mais au moin lé constat
a été fait même le corps était d'accord
avec nos chiffres alors vous voyez que
c'était déjà quelque chose assez
phénoménal aujourd'hui on laisse tout
tomber on ne parle plus de tous les
constats de difficultés que nous en veut
et et des injustices et c'est ça qui va
pas c'est pour ça qu'on a du mal en
terrasse très pâles aux yeux encore enel
je vous entends je vous entends et je
pense que c'est précisément l'objet
cette concertation c'est de repartir de
ce diagnostic qui avait été fait qui
était très riche justement pour pouvoir
avancer à la fois sur la pérennité
financière et sur les corrections du
système actuel vous les avez énuméré où
il ya aussi des injustices le système
actuel et à des injustices donc donc il
s'agit pas de mettre ce dossier
preco vide dans un tiroir il s'agit de
le parc doit partir de l'actualiser
parce que ça fait deux ans pour pouvoir
avancer entre partenaires sociaux et
sous l'égide du ministre heures mystères
du chemin elle très clairement entendu
un c'est le nouveau mac rond qui va
concertée qui va négocier le mot est
important ce n'est pas la même chose
corinne est non ce que je veux dire
c'est que la question de l'âge de la
retraite est au coeur du projet
économique et social et même du projet
d' emmanuel macron pourquoi parce qu'il
veut se servir de la retraite comme d'un
levier pour augmenter le taux d'emploi
pour augmenter la croissance et que les
mesures qui portent sur l'âge rapporte
beaucoup plus d'argent que celle qui
porte sur la durée de cotisation des
fourchettes ça c'est important doit
reparler c'est vrai c'est très difficile
à dire parce que ça dépend évidemment de
l'importance du curseur de la à quelle
hauteur faire un maximum d'économies
c'est là qu'est l'os oui au rural admis
il a il n'a pas arrêté de dire dans ces
éléments de langage pendant la campagne
qu'il fallait travailler plus longtemps
pour pouvoir dégager de l'argent pour
effacer la dépendance cotisations la
soirée et l'éducation oui mais pas au
même rythme et ça rapportera fortement
juste une petite incident je vais vous
montrer un sujet de maele morin très
rapidement pour vous montrer qu' on est
vraiment une exception en europe on a
commencé à en parler avec stéphane
blakowski tour d'horizon des différents
âges de départ à la retraite en europe
et puis je vous redonne la parole juste
après
en moyenne un salarié part à la retraite
à 65 ans dans lieu en france et en suède
on s'arrête de travailler à 62 ans 64
ans en finlande 65 en belgique beaucoup
de pays sont actuellement proches des 67
ans l'italie l'allemagne les pays-bas ou
le danemark on ne part pas non plus au
même âge selon que l'on soit un homme ou
une femme en roumanie un homme peut
arrêter de travailler à 65 ans une femme
à 62 en autriche en pologne ces mêmes
cinq années d'écart seule constante
l'âge de départ à la retraite augmente
progressivement dans tous les pays
objectif 67 ans en belgique d'ici 2030
67 ans aussi en espagne pour 2027 69 au
danemark en 2035 les pays bas vont
encore plus loin l'âge de départ
évoluent en fonction de l'espérance de
vie il se fait huit mois plus tard à
chaque fois que l'espérance de vie
augmente d'une année
philippe aghion il ya parmi nos voisins
européens des pays qui sont gouvernés
plutôt à gauche au centre gauche et
pourtant l'âge de départ est bien plus
éloigné que le nôtre
comment vous l'expliquez et si on ne
doit pas le faire pourquoi les autres
l'ont fait donc notamment moi je propose
d'allonger la durée de cotisation donc
ça ben
oui mais on peut le faire ou plus
lointains oui mais moi j'ai toujours le
problème de l'âge légal c'est que je
pense qu'à cette injustice de que ce que
vous avez un transfert des gens
défavorisés vers des gens déjà favorisés
alors que par la durée de cotisation en
tenant compte de la pénibilité c'est une
rend le fait de manière plus juste en
augmente la de la quantité de voix là et
je pense que ça c'est une et puis je et
puis je voudrais absolument et puis je
crois que les conditions de travail
également je pense qu'il aura tout un
débat sur les conditions de travail vous
savez que le climat dans les entreprises
françaises et souvent mauvais les gens
sont pas heureux dans l'entreprise en
france y aura tout un débat à avoir là
dessus et
ça c'est très bien philippe on avait
écrit un livre là-dessus il ya quelques
années certaines viandes indiqué
laquelle on doit beaucoup s'attacher
également je pense pour donner le goût
de rester plus longtemps au travail il
est exact que la question de la
pénibilité se pousse particulièrement en
france et pas dans les autres pays et
que la question de la pénibilité est
plus souvent une question de travail que
de retraite parce que au lieu d'inciter
les gens à partir plus tôt il faudrait
plutôt travailler à rendre leurs leur
tâche moins pénible allons faire tous
ces volailles sont prononcés aujourd'hui
la pénibilité il ya accident du travail
on a plus d'accidents du travail parce
qu'on n'est pas dans une logique de
prévention comme en allemagne dans les
pays où leur salon il
ya le harcèlement et à le sujet de
l'aménagement des postes du travail
parce qu'on travaille différemment à 40
ans qu'à 60 ans et donc c'est aussi le
sujet de la formation tout au long de la
vie est-ce qu'on a changé à des
compétences au fonds de l'état d'esprit
est ce que vous le sens le sentait ça me
semble bien que les salariés n'ont plus
envie de donner de la même façon à
l'entreprise je crois que locaux vides a
fait changer les choses et on parle
souvent moi je vous parle de l'exécutif
dans la manière dont les gestes ou des
sujets sur la table le sujet à mettre
sur la table c'est l'emploi des seniors
vous dites il faudra travailler dès
trimestre sous quelques années
supplémentaires sont mêlés seigneurie
sens où ils sont chômage donc je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faut déjà
redonner du sens au travail comme le
demande la cftc notamment au niveau des
seniors a plus on va demander de
travailler plus longtemps plus on va se
retrouver des seniors qui sont ni en
emploi ni au chômage ça va être une
véritable catalogue je voudrais
peut-être déçu c'est que en fait les
études toutes les études empiriques qui
existent rejette le risque de hausse du
taux de chômage par substitution des
jeunes sur les seniors il ya un effet
horizons en fait dans les chats fois
qu'on a augmenté durée de cotisation les
entreprises temps d'investir plus sur
les seniors et les analyses
rétrospectives de la réforme de 2010 le
passage de 62 62 ans ainsi que
l'expérience des réformes réalisées dans
d'autres pays montrent qu'en fait les
réformes d'allongement ont augmenté
l'emploi des seniors ne l'ont pas réduit
ça c'est les études en direct qui le
monde mais la logique est justement
celle là c'est que les entreprises
investissent alors plus alors on peut
encourager davantage axes qu'il le fasse
encore plus c est d'amener les deux
pyramides de l'emploi du senior par
rapport à une augmentation de tri mais
cela pyramide et seniors augmente moins
vite que le nombre de trimestre ce qui
veut dire qu'à un moment donné on aura
encore plus de chômeurs et puis il faut
écouter ce que les salles alors je suis
c'est les dames aussi c'est le regard
culturel les entreprises il faut penser
aussi surveillance à l'humain sua passe
par la formation la compétence
l'aménagement des postes du travail
heureusement la loi des leçons
d'activité on comprend que voilà vous
allez tout m sur la table tout est
possible tout est ouvert et et compris
cette réforme touraine qu'il faudrait au
fond faire perdurer si je comprends bien
on travaillait il fallait gagner trois
trimestres c'est ça tous les trois ans
si on peut éviter à 501,2 millions
passée à la fois trimestre tous les deux
ans il ya deux options les ans ils ont
tous les deux ans et il ya tous les deux
ans ou bien tous les ans c'est déjà une
sujet qui avait étudié dans le été
étudiés dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites de 2010 neuf puisqu'il fallait
trouver un moyen de combler les déficits
pour faire la jonction avec la nouvelle
réforme il y avait une commission de
financement qui avait été créée par
edouard philippe à laquelle
participaient tous les syndicats et dans
le cadre de cette conférence pardon de
financement avaient été examinés cette
accélération du tour est là c'est
possible pour la cftc ça c'est possible
à regarder mais joli pour l'instant on
n'en est pas là j'aurais d'abord est bon
c'est sans crainte le ministre mardi je
pense qu'il a aussi des choses à nous
dire on va pas regarder dans le marc de
café ce que va nous dire olivier dussopt
c'est quelqu'un que je connais puisque
j'ai travaillé avec lui je lui a remis
un rapport sur les conditions de travail
dans la fonction publique avec une
députée charlotte le coq et je sais de
la façon dont ils travaillent dont vous
avez ses conseils que ça pourrait durer
combien de temps cette négociation est
bien pour leurs soins parce que déjà une
bonne rentrée on ne l'a où on ne l'a pas
laurent berger voulait absolument que
ont commencé à négocier qu'en septembre
le président de la république avait
annoncé une réforme au parlement dès dès
l'été donc pensant que les négociations
seraient déjà fini donc on remet tout à
plat vous vous dites on va négocier et
il n'y a pas de date butoir c'est ça
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de date
butoir nous on n'en a pas on est
tranquille oui ça j'imagine mais y'a
balle volée dans la maison il faut quand
même se le dire le corps nous donne des
chiffres qui sont pas faramineux mais il
n'y a pas une grande urgence il faut
consulter toile à regarder chez makro
balzer c'est ça que le corps ne regarde
pas bien c'était le premier je pense que
vous étiez macroéconomiques dont je
parlais tout à l'heure le corps de
l'épreuve en ferait la transition
parfaite messieurs mesdames pour savoir
c'est cette réforme allait
financièrement nécessaire ou pas il ya
le corps avec son rapport d'un côté
il ya le gouvernement de l'autre qui
l'allumé qui n'y voient pas forcément
les mêmes conclusions explications avec
marco pogné
augmenter l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ou 65 ans c'était une
promesse de campagne d'emmanuel macron
première raison invoquée la
soutenabilité du système par répartition
nous vivons de plus en plus longtemps le
rapport entre le nombre d'actifs et le
nombre de retraités diminue si on veut
préserver le système de retraite par
répartition il faudra progressivement
travailler un peu plus longtemps alors
faut-il réformer pour équilibrer le
système pas forcément d'après le conseil
d'orientation des retraites en 2020 la
part des dépenses de retraites dans le
pib atteint 14,7 pour cent de la
richesse nationale
mais à partir de 2030 et jusqu'en 2070
les dépenses devraient diminuer pour
atteindre entre 11 et 13% en fonction de
la situation économique pour le corps la
trajectoire semble donc maîtriser on
sait que les réformes qui ont déjà été
faites les réformes touraine qui vont
nous amener à 43 ans de cotisations
la désindexation des retraites sur les
salaires tous un produit comme effet sur
les 30 40 prochaines années une baisse
de la part des retraites dans la vie
dans le dans le paysage se bat et moins
chère alors pourquoi vouloir faire
travailler les français plus longtemps
pendant la présidentielle emmanuel
macron avance un deuxième argument il
s'agit de dégager des moyens budgétaires
pour financer d'autres mesures du grand
âge en passant par la santé ou
l'amélioration de nos pensions puisque
ce que je veux faire c'est ray indexées
les pensions dès le 1er juillet et
pouvoir passer le minimum contributif à
1100 euros tous ces progrès sont surtout
les financer travailler plus longtemps
pour financer l'autonomie mais aussi
l'éducation ou encore la transition
écologique une stratégie contestée par
l'opposition politique jean luc
mélenchon et marine le pen en tête
contestée aussi par les syndicats au nom
de quoi c'est tout travailleur en
reportant l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite qui touchera je le répète ce
que les métiers les plus pénibles où
commencer plus tôt au nom de quoi c'est
à eux de payer la transition écologique
moi j'entends ça j'entends qu'il
faudrait payer la perte d'autonomie la
la le parce qu'il ya un vrai sujet la
perte d'autonomie pourquoi on ne taxe
pas davantage les plus hauts patrie si
emmanuel macron obtient la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale l'examen du texte
pourrait débuter au parlement dès cet
automne
alors un strip panossian qu'est ce que
vous répondez à laurent berger pourquoi
ce sont les travailleurs qui doivent
payer je pense qu'on a un taux
d'activité qui inquiète barre par
rapport aux autres pays européens à la
fois parce qu'on avait un problème qui
est en train de se régler d'entrée des
jeunes sur le marché du travail et parce
qu'on a ça vient d'être évoqué aussi un
taux de seniors qui est plus ba ba pour
tous les sujets qui ont été évoqués
seront donc il ya un vrai sujet de taux
d'activité et de plein emploi qu'il faut
de toute façon de rêver budget qu'a dit
jean luc mélenchon si le plein-emploi
promesse d' emmanuel macron est remplie
en cinq ans de pourtant de chômage ça
fait 6 milliards de plus avec l'activité
plus besoin de réformer les retraites ça
dépend des sujets ensuite il dit sa
séance 8e moi je pense qu'il ya une
vraie urgence on disait le corps quand
même ça c'est des chiffres record qui
était rappelé d'ailleurs dans l'article
de l'opinion s'est dit milliers entre 9
et 11 milliards de déficit chaque année
sur le régime par répartition on sur les
cinq produits donnée le 28 de 6 2028 moi
je prends juste la durée du quinquennat
c'est trop cinquante milliards c'est
trop ça fait cinquante ça fait une somme
de 50 milliards alors cinquantenaire ça
ça veut rien dire
me mignard x 5 sur la durée du
quinquennat c'est l'équivalent je le
disais à dada du budget du miel du
ministère de l'éducation c'est deux fois
et demi le ministère de de l'intérieur
c'est quasiment le ministère de la
défense aujourd'hui alors qu'on a besoin
d'investir plus donc il faut aussi se
dire que c'est il ya une forme de de
responsabilité à la fois à consolider le
régime par répartition est encore aussi
à investir sur l'avenir l'école la
transition énergétique est également
moins je le pense il ya des besoins
urgents autour de l'autonomie du grand
âge et à réparer notre système de santé
corinne l'avion juste après il ya un
vrai problème de une pardon de
diagnostic partagé exacte de la base de
toute réforme réussie il faut que tout
le monde se mette d'accord sur le
diagnostic est là ce n'est pas le cas
premier problème second problème pour
quoi faire on voit bien que laurent
berger dit on veut pas nous les salariés
payés pour l'éducation la santé c'est au
budget de l'état à le faire mais je
pense que la présentation qui a été
faite par emmanuel macron est assez mal
habile parce qu'effectivement présenté
comme ça on se dit il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on paye pour en fait l'idée
c'est de dire qu' il faut que là où on
peut faire des efforts c'est bien
d'arriver à des comptes qu'ils soient à
l'équilibré pour se permettre de faire
des dépenses et être en est donc en vous
en déficit vous il faut réformer le
système financier
non parce que pour qu'on puisse se payer
toutes les retraites ya comme elle à
l'équilibré financier des systèmes de
retraite ken le préalable c'est pour que
les patients soient c'est de clarifier
les besoins de financement dire deux
choses d'abord les dans les prévisions
du cor elle en fait elle repose sur le
fait que le niveau net des pensions va
s'éroder par rapport au revenu net moyen
david est actif parce qu'en fait elles
sont indexés expliqué stade elles sont
indexés pas comme il faudrait voilà les
les pensions des retraites alors voilà
donc on pourrait elle sont pas très bien
à d'ex est donc en partie à cause de ça
qu'ils ont ces prévisions d'équilibré
mais donc ça c'est la première chose
donc qu'on ne souhaite pas puisqu'on
veut revaloriser les retraites tu
comprends on va les mettre à 1100
comprend donc ben ça c'est la première
chose donc le corps il se base sur
l'idée qu'on va mal payés les retraités
bon deuxième chose c'est les effets
macro économique c'est-à-dire quand vous
augmenter le taux d'activité vous aident
ça va ça va donner des revenus à l'état
et ça va donner une crédibilité à l'état
pour pouvoir faire ça donc
d'investissement celle approche draghi
dont je vous ai souvent parlé mario
draghi eh bien il une réforme de l'état
approfondie lui il a déjà fait la
réforme des retraites en italie mais
profonde promet d' approfondir la
réforme de l'état pour être crédible
vis-à-vis des partenaires européens des
marchés financiers pour investir dans
l'éducation la santé etc et nous et nous
c'est vraiment ça c'est l'effet de taux
d'activité l'effet de crédibilité qui
nous permet d'investir et cc c'est là
que c'est une réforme qui est absolument
crucial sinon toute la cohérence du plan
tombe alors présenté comme ça est ce que
ça nous satisfaire les entreprises les
entreprises à augmenter les salaires
faire preuve de partage de la valeur
ajoutée redonner du sens au travail de
façon à ce qu'on puisse payer plus de
cotisations peut-être donner du travail
à nos jeunes donné d'un côté quand même
mais j'espère qu'ensemble des
négociations salariales à l'instant on
voit d'ailleurs que les négociations
sont à l avance fait pour l'instant le
résultat n'est toujours pas quand on
part de la prime macron les 1000 euros
il ya combien de salariés qui ne l'ont
pas triplé y en a beaucoup qui ne l'ont
pas eue la première donc il faut mais à
la discrétion des voisins entreprises en
mémoire la guerre exactement à
discrétion des entreprises certaines
sont vraiment très discrète et les
salariés nous le disent également donc
je pense qu'il faut que si on doit faire
des efforts tout le monde doit faire des
efforts mais à l'heure actuelle je vous
assure que le salarié n'est pas du tout
dans sa tête en train de se dire on va
me demander de travailler plus longtemps
d'abord le diagnostic il faut qu'on
arrive à en parler ensemble pour trouver
les solutions les meilleures mais
laissons faire cette réforme touraine
qui se terminera en 2035 a terminé j'ai
bien entendu le message laissons faire
cette réforme taurine qu'est ce que vous
pensez d'olivier du soft c'est lui qui
va hériter un sous la houlette
d'élisabeth bornes bien sûr de ce
dossier explosif vous disiez que vous le
connaissiez il sait arrondir les angles
et la fait passer des réformes assez dur
mais il a un savoir-faire des coûte
modéré a pour nous il un savoir-faire
des coûte après derrière on a quand même
nos mandants qui sont nos salariés et
les adhérents qu'ils soient à l'ecoute
si c'est la bonne écoute ça ira bien si
c'est la mauvaise écoute on sera aussi
lui dire les choses à un moment donné je
pense que il a pris une responsabilité
importante nous en tant qu'organisation
syndicale cftc on prendra aussi une
responsabilité de protéger le salarié de
protéger le retraité également protéger
aussi l'entreprise il n'est pas question
qu'on envoie nous entrons collé d'une
chose enfin pour conclure philippe
aghion je crois que tant qu on
maintenait l'âge minimum ça voulait dire
pas de négociations avec les syndicats
si maintenant dix ans on met ça en
termes de durée de cotisation d'être
d'accélération tous ont rempoté stable
veron rend possible la négociation avec
les syndicats et je crois que ce qui va
distinguer ce quinquennat du précédent
c'est qu'il y aura une recherche
vraiment la négociation merci beaucoup
le débat évidemment ne fait que
commencer on va en avoir des débats sur
les retraites sur ce bateau c'est une
évidence vous êtes les vous êtes les
bienvenus merci encore on va à présent
accueillir notre grand témoin le
magazine américain time l'a classé parmi
les 100 personnalités les plus
influentes au monde elle est chargée au
sein du giec de préparer notamment le
rapport qui va servir de base la coop 27
qui se tiendra en egypte à l'automne
prochain et malgré tous les signes
catastrophiques du réchauffement
climatique elle refuse de noircir le
tableau et affirme même qu'il n'est pas
trop tard alors on a plein de questions
à lui poser comme les skis ce sujet
d'invitation à valérie masson-delmotte
signé tim willocks
si on vous invite valérie
masson-delmotte c'est qu'il y à un
paradoxe depuis des années vous ne
cessez de le répéter certains des
changements que nous observons
aujourd'hui sont sans précédent depuis
des milliers d'années ou jamais vu
auparavant pourtant malgré vos alarme
nous citoyens continuons d'entendre ça
je fais le serment de léguer une planète
plus vivable ce décalage entre le
discours et la réalité entre l'urgence
climatique et la réaction politique la
climatologue que vous êtes chercheuse au
commissariat à l'énergie atomique et
coprésidente du groupe numéro un du geiq
le connais bien depuis des années vous
n'avez de cesse de documenter le
désastre en cours et d'appeler à une
réaction nous avons des solutions qui
sont en mains l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
de les déployer
j'ai beaucoup de mal en fait avec un
discours qui en fait un discours de
passivité finalement par rapport au
réchauffement climatique à mesure du
réchauffement chaque demi degré compte
la fenêtre pour contenir le
réchauffement d'un degré et demi elle
est maintenue maintenant agir maintenant
une absolue nécessité pour contenir le
réchauffement climatique à 1,5 degrés
seuil crucial réaffirmé dans le d ni
rapport du giec d'ores et déjà près de
la moitié de l'humanité est très
vulnérable face aux dérèglements dernier
exemple en date cette canicule record en
inde jusqu'à 48 degrés est ses brusques
écarts de température à denver de 32 à
-1 degrés en seulement 26 heures alors
pour tenter de conjurer le pire vous
vous engagez lors de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat ou encore lors
du procès du siècle coiffée d'une
perruque de septuagénaires évoquant
trente ans plus tard les errements de
notre présent à ce rythme-là d'action
savait déjà bien à l'époque que ce sera
un réchauffement de l'ordre de 3 degrés
en 2100 valérie masson delmotte
il y a quelques semaines vous avez été
reçu avec d'autres experts par emmanuel
macron le président a au moins entendu
une de vos recommandations
la nouvelle première ministre elisabeth
borne est directement en charge de la
planification écologique une approche
transversale que vous appelez de vos
voeux je pense aux défis climatiques et
écologiques sur lequel il faut agir plus
vite et plus fort alors valérie
masson-delmotte cette nouvelle ambition
y croyez vous pour y répondre quelles
mesures le nouveau gouvernement doit-il
prendre immédiatement
bonsoir valérie masson delmotte et merci
infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation bien on va commencer par
cette question elle vous êtes
directement adressé dans le sujet de
thibaut enoch parce que je crois
vraiment que on a un moment de prise de
conscience sur l'urgence en témoignent
les dernières images de laquelle 10 q
l'an en inde on a vu denver aussi avec
c'est ces écarts ahurissant de
température s'il fallait au fond que
vous soyez aux manettes même si vous
êtes une grande scientifique ce n'est
pas votre rôle mais vous avez vu
emmanuel emmanuel macron récemment
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire tout de
suite en priorité maintenant j'ai envie
de dire deux choses et d'autres choses
qui s'inscrivent dans les évaluations
des rapports du giec qui ne font pas de
recommandations mais qui fournissent un
saut population de dia solution reconnue
par tous la première chose hein c'est un
plan marshall de formation partout dans
les administrations publiques pour les
salariés en formation continue et puis
pour les plus jeunes en fait un à
l'école au collège ou lycée dans les
univers les ministres et pour les
ministres donc je pense qu'il ya un
enjeu qui est de faire monter le niveau
de ce qu'on appelle la littératie
climatique c'est-à-dire comprendre les
causes les conséquences
les enjeux de sorte à comprendre
pourquoi en fait on a besoin de
transformer pas mal de choses de nos
sociétés ça c'est de voir des classes
est important parce que ça veut dire que
nos dirigeants n'ont pas encore compris
un certain nombre de choses c'est ça oui
est un des enjeux vitryate je dirais il
ya trois grands enjeux pour le climat le
premier c'est agir sur les causes
réduire les rejets de gaz à effet de
serre bien sûr sa demande en fait des
compétences pour mettre en priorité ce
qui aura le plus d'effet le deuxième
volet c'est puisque on va vers un
réchauffement qui dans tous les cas va
se poursuivre au moins quelques
décennies tant qu'on n'aura pas atteint
la neutralité carbone au niveau
planétaire s'est arrêté de regarder dans
le rétroviseur mais regardez vers c'est
multiples caractéristiques d'un climat
qui va continuer à changer l'intégrer
dans la prise de décision aujourd'hui ok
besoin encore acquérir les compétences
quand on est affecté par un événement
extrême ou parce qu'on a dépassé un
seuil de tolérance mais à l'avant sans
de sorte à ce que chaque décision qu'on
prend aujourd'hui elle nous adaptons à
un climat qui va continuer à changer et
ça permettra de limiter les risques et
le troisième enjeu s'est allégé la
pression sur les terres on le voit
actuellement on est sur un enjeu majeur
d'insécurité alimentaire le changement
climatique exacerbe ça affectant par
exemple les rendements agricoles mais
avec la sécheresse exactement sécheresse
stress thermique stress hydrique sur les
récoltes en europe sur les récoltes en
inde conditions parfois d'inondations
pluvieuse qui ont touché certaines
récoltes en chine voilà donc le
changement climatique il exacerbe la
pression sur les terres la pression sur
les terres c'est l'interface climat
biodiversité
on a besoin de préserver des écosystèmes
la vie sur terre on a aussi besoin des
terres pour se nourrir et donc rentrer
ça dans l'équation c'est quelque chose
qui est critique et puis le dernier
volet n'est pas évident d'ailleurs avec
le contexte actuel avec les pénurie de
blé à la guerre en ukraine est le
dernier volet s'il y avait quelque chose
que je voudrais souligner c'est ce que
dans les rapports du giec on appelle en
anglais la notion de sufi shan xi alors
c'est souvent traduit en français par
sobriété mais ça n'a pas le même sens et
tout le monde mais des choses
différentes 1 derrière et donc le donc
dans les évaluations scientifiques ça
veut dire à vous utilisez l'énergie les
matériaux pour pouvoir vivre décemment
dans le cadre de limites planétaires
donc c'est pas nécessairement une
restriction c'est permettre à ceux qui
n'ont pas assez de vivre décemment et
puis ce n'est pas la décroissance est là
sur cette formation qu'on entend avoir
un usage raisonnable en fait des
ressources et là en fait on a des enjeux
croisés tensions géopolitiques climat
notre approvisionnement en pétrole en
gaz 1 vient en particulier de russie le
pétrole le gaz ça nourrit le
réchauffement climatique sur réduire un
peu la vitesse sur les routes baisser la
température de chauffage à manger un peu
plus d'aliments à base de plans vous
révoltent pas quand vous voyez les
scandales ça permet aussi d'agir rapport
ne serait ce qu'au pétrole et même au
gaz la france n'est pas si dépendante
par rapport à son voisin allemand par
exemple et on n'a pas fait cette
opération thermostat demander aux gens
de baisser tout petit peu le chauffage
et de pas trop augmenter la clim elle
est faite en italie ouais mario draghi
lave on peut le faire ça coûte rien
c'est d'ailleurs plutôt bon pour le
pouvoir d'achat et sa demande en v vous
adresser au chef de l'état ce soir pour
lui dire il faut le faire ça je pense
que c'est un enjeu particulièrement
important et croiser climat et
géopolitique on veut dire on a
l'impression que souvent
les politiques les états se heurtent sur
ces questions là enfin l'urgence
climatique se heurte à l'action
politique c'est permanent parce que
c'est pas des même temporalité déjà vous
qui avez vu chef de l'état et ce mot
partout dans les journaux de
planification ça veut dire prendre en
compte le long terme qu'est-ce qu'il
vous est dit là dessus est ce que vous
êtes rassurés par rapport à ce tandem
qui arrive sur la transition énergétique
avec l'espagne est relâchée sur la
cohésion des territoires et l'écologie
avec amélie de montchalin en fait moi je
peux pas commenter ni les choix
opérationnels mais qu'est-ce qu'on a les
personnes en a mis derrière ce terme
dans le dialogue que j'avais fait à voir
voilà donc le président de la république
et ses conseillers nous ont écoutés on
était une dizaine d'experts invités
c'est une chance c'est pas le cas dans
tous les pays du monde
ensuite il ya eu une brève une brève
présentation de sa part de points clés
d'un cadre possible de référence
c'est-à-dire c'est à dire justement les
aspects clés d'une vision à plus long
terme et puis ensuite on a eu des
échanges par mails en fait sur le compte
rendu de ces échanges et ça s'est arrêté
là et en fait mon rôle n'est pas moi de
fournir des éléments en appui à des
choix politiques mais par contre au delà
de ce que je fais vizada
au delà de ce que je fais vis-à-vis du
gicl aussi membre du haut conseil pour
le climat qui en fait l'organisme
indépendant qui a été mis en place il ya
quelques années pour évaluer les
politiques publiques et faire des
recommandations et je ne vais pas
m'exprimer sur des intentions mais je
contribue au rapport du haut conseil
pour le climat qui sera rendu fin juin
et qui est une évaluation collective
traçable en fait un basé sur des faits
de l'état des lieux des politiques
publiques en france sur le climat se
souder les entreprises aujourd'hui qui
peuvent avoir le plus d'impact rapport
aux états parce qu'on est dans des cop à
chaque fois discuter sur des engagements
mais qui sont les acteurs qui peuvent je
dirais pas du jour au lendemain mais sur
les dix ans réussir à réduire de façon
vraiment vraiment importantes et surtout
efficace leurs émissions il ya un enjeu
bien sûr au niveau des et hommes il ya
aussi un enjeu au niveau des villes qui
ont beaucoup de clés sur par exemple
l'économie aux circulaires l'efficacité
énergétique l'aménagement les transports
on a également des enjeux majeurs en
france au niveau des régions qui sont
des chefs de file acteurs publication
très important pas seulement pour les
règles du commerce mondial par exemple
au niveau de l'union européenne elle
compte et puis il ya également le rôle
des citoyens et le rôle des entreprises
et des secteurs d'activité ce qui est
noté dans le rapport du giec qui porte
sur la baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est qu'il ya des
facteurs qui poussent à davantage
d'actions les ruptures technologiques
l'innovation
l'engagement de citoyens voyez ça à
l'innovation comme fait par exemple
qu'on puisse levier pour l'année les
véhicules à pétrole par d'autres formes
de mobilité transports en commun vélo
était active et eric de machines
c'est à dire des chose faisable
aujourd'hui et l'évaluation c'est que ça
permettrait de diviser par deux les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde d'ici à 2030 si s'était
déployée donc cette innovation elle est
déjà là d'électricité bas carbone les
pompes à chaleur pour le chauffage
décarbonée c'est pas de la science
fiction ce sont des choses qui sont déjà
là mais ça demande en fait un cadre pour
que ce soit déployé une formation aussi
des acteurs dans le rhin et c'est donc
mais je vous parlais des entreprises le
dire deux choses l'engagement de la
société civile ça compte des
conversations qu'on a sur le climat
l'engagement des plus jeunes ce sont des
choses qui ont changé albert archi au
fond entre les acteurs des entreprises
elles peuvent être des leviers d'action
formidable mais les entreprises pour
certaines d'entre elles ont également
joué et ça a été montré par a plus b un
rôle de lobbying toxiques en freinant
aussi ramène avez dit que vous avez vue
de l'assemblée générale de total energy
aujourd'hui avec ce plan climat qui a
été adopté par près de 90% des des
actionnaires plan climat qui prolonge le
forage des hydrocarbures sur les dix
prochaines années ça savourer bolt
j'imagine en fait chaud d'investissement
euros de chiffre d'affaires à
l'investissement dans les énergies
fossiles ça va verrouiller des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre importantes à
venir et donc des incréments de
réchauffement supplémentaire avec des
coûts croissants pour l'adaptation des
pertes et dommages qui vont toucher en
premier lieu les plus vulnérables on
voit sur ces images les ong les
militants écologistes qui avaient voilà
peu perturbé en tout cas manifesté
devant le siège de total
la clé pour un plan climat qui soit
sérieux c'est qu'il se manifeste par une
baisse effective en valeur absolue des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et je
crois mais je n'ai pas lu la dernière
version que l'agenda de cette entreprise
c'est en fait plutôt un découplage en
relatif par rapport à un chiffre
d'affaires mais pas une baisse
nécessairement absolu de ces émissions
et si on veut réussir à stabiliser le
réchauffement il faut qu'il ait une
baisse entre maintenant et 2030 de
l'ordre de 25 à 50% ouais voilà 25 à 50%
des émissions 25% pour le co2 est
assurée chaudhry et 45 156 et autour
d'un degré c'est un degré et demi en
même temps un tout petit mot parce que
ça change quand même à total énergie il
ya deux actionnaires même un peu plus
notamment les crédits mutuels edmond de
rothschild qui ont voté contre ce plan
climat à la surprise générale est ce que
ça veut dire que les choses changent il
dénonce un faux plan climat en fait si
on prend les options que je décrivais
tout à l'heure dans tous les secteurs
d'activités qui sont disponibles
faisable avec parfois pleins de
bénéfices en termes de santé en termes
d'emploi
quel est le frein un des freins majeurs
c'est la disponibilité de financement et
les évaluations qui sont faites elles
montrent qu'il ya un manque en d'un
facteur 3 à 6 de financement versé
solution est donc l'enjeu c'est
d'arriver à les sortir des énergies
fossiles et de les mettre au service de
ses leviers d'action alors je voudrais
vous ramener au diagnostic de la
climatologue que vous êtes le dernier
rapport du giec était pour le moins
alarmant il ne nous restait au resterait
que trois ans pour agir c'est ce qu'on a
pu lire en une après la publication du
dernier rapport du giec alors vous avez
très signé une tribune dans le monde
expliquant qu'il n'est jamais trop tard
pour agir en faveur du climat qui a mal
compris qui est ce que il ya des
divisions au sein du giec sur la
communication à avoir sur sur le
caractère très alarmant de la situation
où ce sont les journalistes qui ont pris
une phrase qui apparemment a été mal
comprise pour dire que voilà c'était
trois ans où la situation mondiale
n'était plus vivable le rapport du giec
qui montrent en fait que l'enjeu c'est
donc lancé le plus vite possible une
baisse franche
importante à long terme des rejets de
gaz à effet de serre et c'est pas entre
maintenant et 2025 on n'a pas trois ans
qui après c'est le chaos en fait l'enjeu
c'est de créer les conditions
structurelles pour pour cette baisse
donc il n'ya pas de création c'est une
interprétation qui a été fait d'une
agence de presse qui a été relayée
partout mais ça n'est pas le message
principal du rapport du groupe iii du
giec du mot dernier cas des membres du
giec françois gemenne qui s'occupe des
questions de migration qui ont eu des
mots très forts et qu'ils ont dit ces
morts tout simplement les objectifs de
l'accord de paris contenir un ennemi de
1 degré et demi le réchauffement c'est
mort ce sont ses mots et lui il prône
déjà une forme de société de
l'adaptation face aux canicules aux
migrations face aux côtes qu'il va
falloir forcément protéger il est dans
sa est-ce qu'il a raison en fait on y
est dedans on vit déjà avec les impacts
d'un climat qui se réchauffe on est déjà
dans une adaptation mais qui est souvent
réactive pas assez transformationnel et
donc qui fait qu'on n'est pas près par
rapport aux caractéristiques qui vont
continuer à charge à mort est très
important les points importants on va
atteindre un degré et demi dans les
prochains 20 en moyenne sur 20 ans ça
veut dire en fait d'ici à 2030 chaque
année il y aura quasiment une chance sur
deux d'avoir ce niveau là sur un an pour
le climat on parle en moyenne sur une
vingtaine d'années donc on y va en fait
on y va et plus en émet des gaz à effet
de serre plus on y va vite et plus on va
inscrire un réchauffement encore plus
important surtout si on verrouille des
émissions en investissant davantage dans
l'exploration d'énergie fossile donc le
message chaque incréments de riches
allemands comptent chacun crème en
compte chaque tonne de co2 de méthane
éviter compte et le point important de
nommer deux de nos rapports c'est que
c'est pas une action pour le climat en
fait c'est une action pour nous pour nos
conditions de vie pour mission dition de
travail et de ce point de vue là chaque
choix compte merci beaucoup merci
infiniment valérie masson-delmotte je
vous propose de rester avec nous pour
accueillir à présent nos a franchi pour
leur parti pris j'ai nommé ce soir l
amont d'un gamin qui va prony quai comme
chaque fois cette campagne des
législatives avec tout un tas
d'informations coulisses comme elle en a
le secret leur garderie servait relie
également sur de nouvelles sanctions
européennes qui se prépare
sur les oligarques russes et puis
isabelle lasserre qui analyse pour nous
le marchandage politique d'erdogan face
à l'hôte en eau a franchi les voies
ciboure soir à tous les trois récents
jeux ravi de vous retrouvez alors on va
commencer par des législatives comme
chaque soir elsa ce soit vous continuez
à éplucher les candidatures pour les
élections deux des 12 et 19 juin
prochains depuis vendredi les listes
sont publiés sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur il peut dresser un portrait
robot du du candidat oui même des
candidats il y en à
6293 je ne vais pas vous les cités un
par un ça fait en moyenne 11 par
circonscription c'est moins qu'il ya
cinq ans et ça s'explique notamment et
bien par l'union à gauche âge moyen 49
ans la parité n'est toujours pas
atteinte 44 2 % sont des femmes bonnet
d'âne pour les républicains qui n'ont
investi que 35 8% de femmes côté mixité
sociale on repassera également les
cadres et les professions
intellectuelles sont sur-représentés 48
% contre 4 % d'ouvriers candidats et
parmi ses plus de 6000 candidats il y en
a des plus ou moins connus et même des
vieux à la télé je crois oui on peut
même parler de stars myriam quelques-uns
effectivement vous pouvez le voir
laurent baffie le sniper du paf se
présente pour le parti animalistes à
paris la chef cuisinière babette de
rozières elle est candidate elle dans
les yvelines isabelle seguin c'est une
des gagnantes de koh lanta elle se
présente pour la majorité c'est pas
l'épreuve des poteaux cette fois c'est
l'épreuve des urnes gérald dahan
l'humoriste spécialiste des imitations
portent les couleurs de la nuque en
charente-maritime et puis francis
lalanne je crois qu'il était chanteur
avant de tourner anti vaccins et lui les
candidats en charente alors tous ces
candidats ont quand même peu de chances
d'être élu alors pour ce qui est fort on
leur leur rentrée en revanche à
l'assemblée ils savent déjà ce qui les
attend c'est un texte un paquet
législatif c'est comme ça que l'exécutif
l'appel sur le pouvoir d'achat oui
évidemment la condition c'est que le
gouvernement obtienne bien la majorité
mais effectivement l'exécutif a prévu de
s'attaquer à ce qu'il considère comme
une urgence dès cet été le pouvoir
d'achat avec vous en reparler
l'indexation des retraites sur
l'inflation le dégel du point d'indicé
le bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz ou
l'électricité
une commission va donc être sollicités
très très rapidement c'est la commission
des finances et vous le savez peut-être
sa présidence elle va un membre de
l'opposition alors jean luc mélenchon et
la nuque espère bien à défaut de gagner
les élections législatives direct le
principal groupe d'opposition ici à
l'assemblée mais un insoumis à la tête
de la commission des finances eh bien ça
donne quelques sueurs froides dans la
majorité ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'on a bien relu attentivement la le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale pour
y lire article 39 alinéa 3 ne peut être
élu à la présidence de la commission des
finances qu'un député appartenant à un
groupe s'étant déclarés groupes
d'opposition oui mais il n'était écrit
nulle part que c'est le principe
dans les détails du règlement de
l'assemblée hier elle devant dans les
prochains prochain jeu merci infiniment
elle a réservé dès ce soir faut-il
reconstruire l'ukraine avec les avoirs
russes gelé et pourquoi pas même
confisqué c'est bien ça la commission
européenne planche sur de nouvelles
sanctions effectivement c'était l'objet
d'une annonce se fait à bruxelles
aujourd'hui alors sur le papier l'idée
de confisquer les avoirs russes je
laissais plutôt séduisant la commission
européenne qu'est ce qu'elle a déclaré
aujourd'hui elle crée elle veut créer
pardon une infraction pénale de non
respect des sanctions cela permettrait
d'ouvrir une action judiciaire contre
toutes les entités qui ne respectent pas
les ne respectant pas les sanctions
deviendraient donc répréhensibles au
regard de la loi alors jour résume
l'idée c'est de traiter les avoirs
russes gelé comme ceux de la mafia
italienne il existe une législation de
ce type en italie ou bien comme les
biens mal acquis des dictateurs
africains ça doit vous dire quelque
chose voilà donc une manne disponible
dans laquelle il serait possible de
puiser pour financer la reconstruction
de l'ukraine qui coûtera sans doute des
centaines de milliards d'euros alors
dans le collimateur il y a déjà un
pactole c'est les 300 milliards d'euros
d'avoirs de la banque centrale russe qui
sont gelés en europe mais il y a
derrière les yachts des eaux ligue à
leur compte bancaire leurs propriétés
immobilières rien qu'en france les
immeubles gelé
représenterait environ un milliard
d'euros l'organisation transparancy
international qui est spécialisée sur la
lutte anticorruption vient de déposer
une plainte devant le parquet national
financiers contre plusieurs oligarques
pour blanchiment non justification de
ressources recel et complicité et tout
ça dans l'espoir d'ouvrir une procédure
judiciaire alors
c'est pas si simple myriam car qui dit
confiscation dit état de droit et oui la
propriété privée fort heureusement et
dans l'union européenne un droit
fondamental
défendu par un arsenal juridique mais
aussi par la jurisprudence de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
confisquer il faut en général avoir
d'abord jugé que le détenteur des avoirs
est coupable d'un crime la confiscation
devient éventuellement une réparation
c'est le cas en italie en général
destiné aux victimes alors pourquoi ils
ouvrent la voie alors voilà c'est pas
possible et bien évidement par ce
qu'envisageait là convient que la
confiscation c'est une menace c'est une
menace adressée aux oligarques et à
l'état russe cela donne une arme à tout
le monde y compris les douaniers
français dans leurs investigations cela
donne aussi aux diplomates un argument
lorsque les biens de certains dirigeants
politiques seront directement concernés
et ça constitue surtout un levier sur
les banques et les institutions
financières qui sont toujours tenté de
cacher les à bois russe ou ne pas donner
les bénéficiaires réels derrière les
sociétés offshore l'objectif c'est donc
de faire comprendre à tous les
intermédiaires qu'une guerre économique
et financière est bel et bien en cours
et que toute tentative de dissimulation
peut s'apparenter à une trahison je
voyais très attentive une toute petite
réaction là dessus on a beaucoup dit la
guerre en ukraine et le climat ne sont
pas forcément allié au contraire on peut
justement utilisées entre guillemets
cette situation pour opérer un tournant
par rapport à toutes les énergies
fossiles en fait c'était pas sur ce
point dès que j'avais envie de réagir
c'était sur les gravats les deux ans une
pensée pour ma collègue climatologues
ukrainienne suite l'anah krakovska qui
avait mené une des sessions
d'approbation d'un des rapports du giec
depuis son appartement bombardé à kiev
j'espère que y aura une aide rapide pour
la reconstruction des systèmes de
recherche des universités il ya des
banques de semences ans qui ont été
détruites et puis j'espère aussi en fait
que s'il ya un mécanisme en fait de
réparation qui pourra aussi adressé
quelque part la crise alimentaire
mondiale qui a entraîné par ce conflit
le changement climatique contribue en
fait par le stress thermique le stress
hydrique les chocs sur les récoltes a
affecté le système alimentaire c'est un
conflit en plus et on voit qu'en fait on
a un système alimentaire qui est très
vulnérable merci beaucoup alors il nous
reste un peu moins de temps murray vous
écoutez attentivement isabelle vous nous
parler ce soir du coup de force
d'erdogan face à l'otan il veut bloquer
grâce à son veto à l'otan l'entrée de la
suède et de la finlande oui puisque
après après des années de doutes et
d'introspection ou plutôt de mort
cérébrale comme disait emmanuel macron
l'otan a été ressuscitée par vladimir
poutine et il a retrouvé à la fois sa
raison d'être mais aussi son
attractivité puisque deux nouveaux
membres la suède et la finlande donc pas
n'importe lesquels frappe à sa porte
mais la fête était sans doute trop belle
et erdogan le président turc a décidé de
la gâcher en menaçant d'utiliser son
veto pour empêcher l'intégration des
deux états nordiques dans l'alliance
atlantique alors officiellement il leur
reproche d'héberger sur leur territoire
des membres du pkk considéré comme une
organisation terroriste à ankara son il
est possible aussi que son chantage vise
à obtenir des contreparties de la part
des autres membres de l'otan par exemple
une levée de l'embargo européen sur les
armes qui avait été décrétée en 2019
après l'intervention de la turquie
contre les kurdes en syrie est lourde et
en est les alliés des etats unis contre
l'état islamique ou alors ou alors
myriam le l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
crise au sein de l'otan vise à faire
oublier les énormes difficultés
économiques du pays avant les élections
l'année prochaine et cr dogan ménager
moscou également avec ce chantage alors
bien sûr c'est sans doute une façon pour
lui de donner des gages à son ami à son
ami vladimir poutine qu'il a froissé en
livrant des drones ultra performant aux
ukrainiens en tout cas en brisant
l'unité de l'otan il est certain qu'il
rend un fier service au maître du
kremlin et ce n'est pas la première fois
il avait déjà ouvert erdogan une crise
majeure au sein de l'alliance atlantique
en 2017 en achetant un système de
défense anti missile russe et femmes
es400 complètement incompatible avec les
équipements occidentaux il est aussi
aujourd'hui le seul pays de l'otan avoir
refusé d'appliquer les sanctions
économiques imposées à la russie au
début de la guerre on avait un petit peu
l'impression d'un mot qu'il était rentré
un peu dans le rang on avait
l'impression il avait effectivement
appuyé sur le frein parce que ses coups
d'éclat avait fini par le marginalisée
en 2020 la turquie avait multiplié les
provocations en méditerranée en forant
des hydrocarbures sous la protection de
bateaux de guerre dans les eaux
territoriales de la grèce et de chypre
les relations étaient aussi très très
mauvaise avec emmanuel macron mais ça
s'était calmé mais avec qu'erdogan le
calme précède toujours la tempête et
c'est vrai que les membres de l'otan
déjà été très très patient avec lui et
aujourd'hui la question qui est
complètement tabou à l'alliance
atlantique est à nouveau sur certaines
lèvres la turquie at elle encore sa
place dans l'atlantique alors l'occident
sait qu'on va faire à nourrir vos
prochaines chroniques occident nous
estimer la menace de vladimir poutine on
a vu ce que ça a donné en ukraine ce
qu'il fera la même erreur avec erdogan
merci infiniment merci isabelle et merci
à vous valérie masson-delmotte d'avoir
accepté notre invitation les affranchis
à très très vite parce que c'est la fin
de cette émission va regarder ensemble
ce documentaire parce que c'est
l'excellent françois chevré ce soir
journaliste à el tp qui a fait le pari
de suivre pendant dix ans des jeunes de
la génération 2008 cet appel qui seront
ils demain épisode 2 dans la tête d'ado
de 12 13 ans ça vous regarde à prendre
quelques jours de congés pour
l'ascension toute l'équipe que je
profite il a même remercié va revenir
mardi soir prochain très belle soirée
[Musique]